comme tous les vendredis rendez vous
avec la télévision régionale d'hier
aujourd'hui nous faisons un bond de 15
ans en arrière direction cognac le
festival du film n'était pas encore
lancée mais les professionnels de l'audi
avait déjà pris l'habitude de faire
venir les vedettes en avions regardé la
foule était nombreuse en ce matin du 27
octobre 1973 sur l'aérodrome de cognac
invité d'honneur des vendanges jacques
martin le célèbre comique dans
l'émission le petit rapporteur est très
apprécié dans les foyers français
tous les dimanches monsieur jacques
martin était accompagnée en la
circonstance de son épouse l'actrice
danielle evenou tous deux aux pêcheurs
aux produits régionaux lors de cette
journée de détente où l'on a beaucoup ri
bond vient vanter un peu quand rigole
avec les grandes pattes qui vont traîner
tu l'as fait rare en propre les temps
raconte avec un poids comme le mien
serrières sort la changeant fonds sera
formidable
c'est bien ça peut être qu'avant je vais
t'ouvrir suivez moi vous allez voir
écartez vous